لذلك أقر آلان ويسبرغ للتو بأنه مذنب في
15 تهمة جنائية ، كل ذلك جزء من
لائحة اتهام الاحتيال الضريبي هذه التي اتهم
بها العام الماضي الآن كجزء من هذه
الاتفاقية التي وافق على الاعتراف بالذنب
ضد ترامب أو الشهادة ضد
المنظمة الرابحة عندما يذهبون  إلى
المحاكمة في أكتوبر ، كان ويسيلبيرج
أحد كبار الضباط في منظمة ترامب
التي كان يقود الشركة
مع أبناء الرئيس السابق عندما
أصبح دونالد ترامب رئيسًا وذهب
إلى البيت الأبيض ، لذا فإن ويسبرغ
مطلوب كجزء من اتفاق الإقرار هذا
للإدلاء بشهادته في  محاكمة المنظمة الرابحة
الآن بموجب هذه الصفقة ،
مطلوب منه أيضًا سداد ما يقرب من
مليوني دولار من الفوائد الضريبية
والغرامات المستحقة عليه ، لكن في جزء من
هذه الصفقة ، لن يتعاون
مع محامي مقاطعة مانهاتن
المستمر على نطاق واسع-  نطاق
التحقيق في المنظمة الرابحة
وما إذا كانوا قد ضللوا
أي مقرضين أو شركات تأمين أو غيرهم حتى يكون
التحقيق مستمرًا  لن تتعاون g و whitesburg
كجزء من ذلك ، ولكن سيكون
هناك انتصار كبير
لمكتب المدعي العام في مانهاتن الذي رفع
هذه القضية ضد آلان ويسبرغ
والمنظمة الرابحة ألين
ويسلبرغ للإدلاء بشهادته في
محاكمة الشركة في وقت لاحق من هذا العام